this week we've got baby Sanders off my
lawn and googly eyes oh I think I know
what that one's my guess all right for
the first story KFC has announced that
they will pay someone eleven thousand
dollars if they name their baby after
Colonel Sanders both know what the heck
okay someone get me pregnant so just got
a name a name the baby colonel yeah
daughter his name is Harlan Oh Harland
Sanders land Harlan Oh Harlan I like
Harlan it's a cool name so that's it yes
it's a great name for your baby just say
it out loud Harland plus you're greatly
named kid could get $11,000 could the
question is the board's put if I was
broke I totally do this right okay so
this is what you need to do in order to
be eligible you have to have a baby born
in the US on September 9th and name them
Harlan and then you submit the
information once you've checked all
those boxes and then you submit to this
page called baby Harlan page no later
than October 9th a lot of work for
Jessie will have to give birth you know
what they're trying to do this is what
they do to the Dalai Lama and they're
trying to rebirth the soul of Colonel
Sanders through this baby that's creepy
yes some like necromancer [ __ ] yep this
is like they're trying to summon the
soul of that sweet Kentucky man is he
sweet circle yes she's gonna one side
have you ever try this recipe he looks
like he owned a lot of people Fried
Chicken experts taste testers but don't
you think this is dangerous I feel like
a lot of woman are gonna like try to
force a birth yeah that day yeah cuz
it's in the next couple days
yeah cuz they want $11,000 three months
but [ __ ] it get in there what if they
put like c-sections don't count like
forced first don't count I don't know if
you can force a birth though okay just
pull the baby out a jeweled c-section
but that's scheduled and the doctor has
to clear you right like do you really
get to pick you can't call a doctor
hey I want it on this date [ __ ] yeah
sure you probably could and they could
like induce the birth right you like
you've got shot you can pick a date if
the doctor says well in this week which
day of the week do you want to have your
baby and that's when we're gonna
schedule your c-section I see but they
are saying though that the first baby
born in the day that's all the lean
earliest the earliest one will be the
winner for the Webber's at 12:01 or at
12:12
oh yeah so whoever pushes faster like
all the moms that they're like I had
just come out and you wanna which head
is coming out first they're all in a row
yeah watching that so they're just a
bunch of ladies with their legs out like
this and a [ __ ] baby about to pop out
and
count of three buh-bah and I just start
pushing zooms in on the [ __ ] chai and
baby three takes the lead you know like
the hot in the in the carnival games and
you're playing like the water and then
the horse is going baby
carne I'm [ __ ] up because all I was
thinking was that whack-a-mole game but
China just tucked the baby thought pop
yeah you don't watch the baby though
what is the purpose marketing I guess
like you know can see come up with our
crazy [ __ ] sometimes so this is just
another one it does sound more like
their Carl's jr. stuff you know culture
is crazy okay so you just seems like
they just rely on like the old
traditions of Kentucky really no they do
a lot it well I can't think of one off
the top of my head but I know they've
done some other marketing [ __ ] yeah they
only follow like seven people oh that
one 1111 people because it's 11 herbs
and spices yeah is they only so they
followed all the Spice Girls and like a
bunch of guising herbs herbs that's dope
yeah it's really cute it's super old
wood you guys how they take the $11,000
or a lifetime supply of KFC $11,000 for
life [ __ ] I'm gonna pay for it I'll
take 11,000 and then I'll go to bus is
Fried Chicken I rather do yeah I would
do a different chicken shop Louisiana
style fried chicken or churches maybe or
just any food like any restaurant which
one would you pick last lifetime supply
may be full of Abell over in and out
fast food right you're so fast we're
gonna know because they got sure things
everything too much pressure
i'ma get out of this conversation if you
just can you got a narrow it down from I
don't like how about grocery store
restaurant restaurant damn it now most
Twitter accounts cuz they're technically
a restaurant it's gonna be a chain to be
a change yeah I'm just
saying because cheese a factory has a
variety of everything they do you know
and everything's decent yeah and
everything's decent so you never miss it
that's a good choice really I feel like
but you never get that one thing oh no I
have that one thing there what do you
have what do you the pasta DaVinci
that's really good
it's just bomb I only get one thing
that's I would have known that Suzie
Gena Cheesecake Factory
I had to upgrade my thoughts I was like
at the fast-food level now you just
change the game on me I remember I was
young and I thought the Cheesecake
Factory was like the lists like fancy
[ __ ] this Tony Romo still exists oh [ __ ]
Tony Roma's Italian probably not it was
a steak house and ribs and oh they have
really good beef ribs
but I remember it was good when I was a
kid then you were fancy
you weren't poor then Tony Roma's I
would get it on my birthday that's right
that's it though we were always Tony
Roma's I would get it on my birthday
birthday birthday birthday Tony Romo
call my birthday I'm a birthday I'm a
birthday so not Chuckie Cheese but Tony
Roma's
Tony Roma's yeah my dad would buy me
some beef ribs that's bomb but I
remember guys worried she went to some
Tony Roma's and it was really bad like
sizzle exists anymore
I would guess no maybe I haven't even
made my decision I can't do it you
[ __ ] us where else can you get every I
know I can't even decide myself I think
I would get pie if it's fast food I'm
going with Shake Shack
Oh is that fast food it's bougie box I
know it's a little bit above map and
then you get like just forever like you
don't have to spend money on that I say
we all have that's why I prefer a back
over in and out yep I'm right there with
you like we gotta go my post mates
people you know you wait longer no you
gotta get that at the stores it out she
times it up you can't get you can't post
mate Shake Shack you gotta get it at the
store you can
if you want have you ever posed made it
in and out it's probably chr''o no I've
been wanting I would never do that way I
don't think you can post me it's in or
not can you know I don't know I don't
know it's not a metal pass our
sacramental friends say you can but I
have never seen in and out popup on : I
personally think fries you cannot eat
like after 30 seconds in and out
specific Amy fries any price after 30
seconds like if I ever had really old
McDonald's fries are really good you
like that soggy [ __ ] alone but you don't
like that talking she loves love your
friends yeah Olympus
if I have time I ask them to make the
fries fresh can't do that you can't do I
like hard on the outlet it took me a
girl I like rough exterior but soft on
the she likes them she likes herself
like a brownies yeah give me a crunch on
the outside but then all soft you know
in buoys alright so for our next story
this man erected an electrified fence
yeah little cut she met I don't use my
own words in these stories what he did
here right so he erected this electric
fence I picture his dick getting caught
in it in it you got the reason why this
is making music because his home is
right across the street from a bus stop
and so there's kids there waiting for
their bus oh no like just my friend
oh no that's her skits touch everything
jump into conclusions we don't know why
he's doing it yet because we can't go
downhill on yes she's froggy kid
electric [ __ ] for long [ __ ] me some
whatever the [ __ ] those [ __ ] way
just fry them it depends on the voltage
depends on the voltage I want to see the
kid touch it and go and you see
see-through and you [ __ ] see the
skeleton it's my child okay cause I mean
I put you drastic park when Timmy got on
the [ __ ] fence and then she goes
right it was fake right oh no when you
flew off yeah they turned on their
friends we need a fry these puppies over
these little [ __ ] snot-nosed little
bags it depends on how old the kids are
Oh 13-inch oh teenager yeah yeah they're
like kindergartners not everyone thought
what do we pull them kids if they were
teenagers sometimes people do that to
give more debt more sympathy
I don't know agree still article kids
are in like they're teenagers
[ __ ] them high voltage so I'm going to
show you guys a video of his interview
Oh that'd be sick if I was a kid because
we in my mind you guys changed it to a
skeleton know that yeah that and then
they're teenagers now and how people
discover that it was electric battery do
parts land I'll let your friend says
let's [ __ ] off exam it probably like
when they're near it they could probably
sense it
let's hope so here we go people around
here litter people around her oh god he
looks like the type is it reduces
passing sighs he loves his sister for
sure my sister cousin I have to back off
for breath stops oh there are signs it's
on the tree the things right is not go
away like don't step on a part now this
isn't my yard as big as I thought it was
the message ISM has gotten across I'm
pretty sure to everybody it's all over
social media y'all are out here
neighbors are driving by my own parents
are posting and talking about
so yeah I mean the points gotten across
did you hear the reason why he took it
down why cuz everyone's doing no cuz he
was like well I mean I guess my lawn
isn't as big as I thought it was because
he was putting out povery oh no back on
the other side like hopping this fence
non-stop no I'm with the kids so you
thought I was his property it wasn't
even his property defense aw yeah so it
was his lawn but he liked to the extent
of like legally his property he went too
far Oh got it
also it was like at one point the city's
property yeah okay I'd walk I yelled at
someone for that like remember the guy
that was yelling at us for our dog like
[ __ ] up his rosebush and he was like
I was just standing there because he's
being a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then he was like get off my property
and I'm like [ __ ] is a sidewalk this
ain't your property [ __ ] you people are
weird they don't understand how the city
works the sidewalks not yours or some
[ __ ] like they just like oh well that's
my bushes dude that's across the street
it's like you know people are insane my
I used to live next to a Korean neighbor
so it was like two communes next to each
other and she decided to put up a fence
so she paid for the fencing the neighbor
took her - what is that HOA meeting wall
that's like less than half a foot like
the fence was onto her property so
there's like this long move it like half
a foot just born yeah Wow like you're
Korean like usually they cut you some
five does your own ask first
no she also bulldoze through that so
because typically what people will do if
they're setting up a fence or whatever
they'll talk to their neighbor and be
like hey I'm thinking about doing a wall
and then they'll make an agreement and
stuff like that's nice I don't even know
that etiquette yeah me neither
really I just feel like my property is
my property why do I have asked right we
are you guys build a fence on your
[Music]
because it's like common courtesy
because you might build one that's way
higher than what you did before then
what existed before that could block
their view or they're just not ours
I learned something today it's only
because I know because my family built a
fence and then they were like they did
that to their neighbor I was like oh
that's what you supposed to do oh they
asked yeah yeah yeah yes yeah they
talked about it and and they're like
okay let's do these because my dog Huey
was destroying the fence cuz he kept
jumping on it and then he almost bit the
my neighbor's head literally yeah Oh cuz
he was jumping you know like like
jumping and like [ __ ] Mario kids
waiting oh dude
if they get shocked I'm suing the [ __ ]
out of them yeah tell my kids that [ __ ]
come on make mommy somebody to record
the whole I'm making money off my little
bit you like push them a little bit
you're walking by just if my kid was old
enough to be at the bus stop alone and
got electrocuted there's like clear
signs then it's like kids are stupid and
curious you know like cuz you know some
kids stick the fork in the [ __ ] a
socket but I'm thinking that they're old
enough to be there without me right cuz
like when you're young I'm like I get
the curiosity but when you're like 16
and you're like going around touching
fun says I feel like you deserve to be
shook no yeah we're having as the kids
fault me too why you [ __ ] with
neighbors [ __ ] says you yeah you you
should emphasize with kids cuz you were
a wild child yeah but if he got shocked
he didn't blame nobody if I was running
across my neighbor's lawn and he had one
of those [ __ ] beatin Amis bamboo traps
put the [ __ ] bamboo and that's like
sharp and I fell into it is that true is
that what your people do yeah that's
that's what they used to do like this I
tell we get
husbands the tunnel warfare if they did
that to me and I had a [ __ ] bamboo
going through my calf I would never run
across my neighbor's lawn but because my
neighbor's lawn was so safe I ran across
that [ __ ] every day
I should was mine too last story here
this shop in Kuwait had to be shut down
because they were using googly eyes on
fish to sell them off and them being
fresh fish body they thought they could
pass a fast one on people with that yeah
that is hilarious
god it's so good what's the accent that
they would have because I want to hear
the way I sing it yeah on Hume does that
snow I think that's Middle East yes I'm
Middle Eastern air okay yeah like how
would you like that's amazing
because the only thing I'm thinking like
throw up bro I have an idea yeah googly
eyes dude
the super like the clown red-nosed - on
a fish but yeah they're just trying to
pull a fast one on something so finally
someone realized it when they were ready
finally it took a while finally someone
not because they bought it they took it
home and then like when they were almost
home they realize that the googly eye
fell off you know what though I could
kind of relate because sometimes when
I'm buying groceries I just grab [ __ ] so
fast and I don't I don't look so then
sometimes I'll roll with some rotten ass
what you don't do like the produce check
with noise I should but sometimes I just
kind of like eyes good enough good
enough and then focus and when I get
home I'm like [ __ ] this mangles [ __ ]
halfway rotten
I think like the cashier doesn't even
give you a heads up they're like [ __ ]
weirdo if it's an Asian market [ __ ]
they're like hell yeah someone got it
can imagine someone just pick up the
fish in his eyes which is all jiggly
everywhere and you doesn't care the baby
on their way home they realize like are
they just staring at the fish they don't
put it up chopped it up we just put it
down the ice the wiggling efforts done
moving it's [ __ ] great doesn't it
smell like [ __ ] I know this isn't fresh
anymore but they're not trying to do
like pass off old fish right they just
want to make regular fish no they're
trying to pass off old full [ __ ] because
regular fresh fish won't have these
yellow let's say they're steaming you
just steamed of pasta guy look what is
that if they probably they don't care as
long as it's sold yeah they're lucky
they went they went to the party store
and [ __ ] [ __ ] I do want to see the
wrong size on the fish like the I like
this big various ones were different
size fishes too good I love this store
they deserve to be open Kuwait
no well they're not open anymore because
Kuwait's Ministry of Commerce and
Industry shut them down after this story
best [ __ ] can you imagine the inspector
coming over there like I know and you
hear it too
rattling the [ __ ] rattle oh oh it's
so good I knew this [ __ ] about us out
[ __ ] stupid they are
[Music]